[Music]
just last summer at the San Diego
comic-con Kevin Feige scott derrickson
and leading actor Benedict Cumberbatch
presented first information about dr.
strange to model has now confirmed to
variety that derrickson will no longer
direct dr. strange on the directors
twitter channel you can also read there
due to creative disagreements he will no
longer work as a director but will still
be an executive producer what's behind
the inconsistencies was of course not
revealed by both sides one factor could
be the fact already announced at
comic-con that dr. strange too will be
the first horror movie of the MCU at
that time there were already doubts
among fans and journalists after all
Marvel's known for his mostly
family-friendly blockbusters derrickson
who among other things was involved in
the horror movie sinister and The
Exorcism of Emily Rose as director may
have been dr. strange too not dark
enough however this is all pure
speculation and it will probably never
come to light where the collaboration
failed in the end but Marvel fans should
be at least reassured regarding the
release stage because the cinema release
on May 7 2021 is not yet in danger if
the successor can be found quickly the
planned production start in May this
year is not unrealistic in 2017 Disney
and screenwriter Colin Trevorrow parted
ways the creative direction was then
taken over by JJ Abrams and his version
of Star Wars the rise of Skywalker has
now been running in the cinemas for
several weeks
many fans naturally wonder what the
original version by Trevor o and his
colleague Jerry Connelly would have
looked like filmmaker Robert Mayor
Burnett may have an answer to this
question as he allegedly got his hands
on a script that turned out to be the
first draft of Trevor o and Connelly
screenplay the title at the time was
steel Star Wars Episode nine jewel of
the faith's in contrast to the rise of
Skywalker the content is of course a
little different one of the most
fundamental differences is probably the
role of Palpatine because in duel of the
fates he's not the main villain
furthermore Luke Skywalker seems to play
a bigger role in this version and the
script is closer to Star Wars the last
Jedi the bottom line is that the
authenticity of this script has never
been confirmed by Disney so any content
should be treated with caution
the double-oh-seven produces Michael G
Wilson and Barbara broccoli announced to
top-class musical additions firstly hans
zimmer who's known worldwide for his
epic sea music will replace the composer
dan roma roma is no longer part of the
bond team as creative differences are
said to have led to resentment on both
sides the two producers seem to be very
enthusiastic about Simha and in a
statement they revealed that their
collaboration with Zima is a dream come
true and that they are more than
thrilled that Zimmer will take over the
bond squad for bond 25 soon I can look
back on a very successful career among
his most famous projects are the music
from The Lion King in 1994 and the music
for inception Zimmer even won an Oscar
for best film music the artist who will
sing the title song to bond 25 is 44
years younger than Aunt Emma loved and
hated in equal measure 18 year old Billy
Eilish is simply impossible to ignore at
the moment
her debut album when we all fall asleep
where do we go sold in the USA in 2019
by far the most frequent a Tuesday the
official double-oh-seven
Twitter account released the statement
that finally confirmed the rumour that
appeared a few days earlier making
Eilish the youngest musician with a Bond
theme song she follows in the footsteps
of Adele and Sam Smith who both produced
the last theme songs for the Bond films
and also won an Oscar for best film song
director Cary Fukunaga is also very
excited about the new song which is
already finished and said he's looking
forward to the audience hearing it this
will be possible with the release of
James Bond develops have no time to die
on April 20 2020 in the USA a few days
ago the first trailer for Morbius was
released in which the antihero played by
Jared Leto meets vulture the villain
from spider-man homecoming this supports
the rumors of the last days that the new
Morbius movie will have some overlaps -
spider-man and the MCU in the trailer
you can see scientist and vampire
Michael Morbius walking past a
spider-man graffiti with a title
murderer and then meets Adrian Toomes a
cave ultra many fans are now speculating
that vultures appearance might be a hint
that the sinister six will appear soon
the sinister six
are akan glamorous of spider-man
villains and originally consist of
vulture electro Kraven the hunter
Mysterio Sandman
and a leader dr. octopus Allegiant Lee
Sony has been planning its own spin-off
for this sinister six for quite some
time if you take spider-man homecoming
and spider-man far from home together
you would have a couple of candidates
with vulture Chaka and the Scorpion and
carnage which have only been shown in
the post-credits so far it could be
included in the sinister six if Sony
does indeed expand the sinister sake
storyline it doesn't necessarily mean
that they will also face spider-man the
already announced spider-man 3 which
will be released in 2021 should at least
get along without the sinister six it's
unlikely that these villains will appear
in the MCU anyway since Kevin Feige has
already spoken out against implementing
these villains in the MCU in the past
more likely is an appearance of
spider-man in a Sony villain movie maybe
the upcoming Morbius movie will tell us
one or the other secret the release date
is July 31st 2020 over the past month
new information about the actors in the
upcoming Lord of the Rings series has
been announced bit by bit now amazon has
announced the full cast at the
Television Critics Association already
known were the engagements of Robert
romão as beldo Morfitt Clark as
Galadriel Joseph Maul is Oren mikela
Cavanaugh as female Lee Tyra and Emma
Hall worth in a yet unknown role the new
faces are Owen Arthur Nazanin Boniadi
Tom budge Ismael Cruz Cordova ty Rome we
are feeding Sophia naam VJ Megan
Richards Dylan Smith Charley Vickers and
Daniel Wayman therefore at least from a
personal point of view nothing stands in
the way of the filming which will begin
in February
however only the first two episodes will
be shot another direction of Juan
Antonio Bayona before the plans for the
second season are finalized and the
scripts for season 1 are completed s in
the film trilogy in New Zealand will be
the main location the first season of
Lord of the Rings will be available on
Amazon Prime video later in 2021
in the field of world-famous
thrillers there is no way around the
Silence of the Lambs with Anthony
Hopkins in the role of the notorious
Hannibal Lecter but at least as iconic
was the portrayal of FBI agent Clarice
Starling played by Jodie Foster already
in 2012 there
an unsuccessful attempt to produce a
series around Starling now there will be
a new attempt and US broadcaster CBS
will take on such a series called
Clarice the plot will be set in 1993 one
year after the filming and will focus on
agent Stallings dealings with other
serial killers and sex criminals
according to the current state of
affairs the pilot episode is supposed to
be finished already whether this will
also convince the CBS station is of
course the other question before that
can happen an actress has to be found
who's suitable for the role of Clarice
Starling and of course many fans also
wonder if Hannibal Lecter will play a
role in the series if you believe a
report from deadline this will most
likely not be the case how the series
will continue remains to be seen the
nominations for the film industry's most
important award have now been published
in the following you will find an
overview of the nominations that we
consider to be the most important but of
course this does not claim to be
complete at the top of the list the
industry's favorites Joker with leading
actor jock in Phoenix has received 11
nominations including Best Film Best
Director Best leading Actor and best
camera close to that is the Netflix
mafia epic the Irishman with 10
nominations including Best Picture Best
directing twice in Best Supporting Actor
Best Adapted Screenplay and best
production design also nominated ten
times are Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
as well as the world war drama 1917 in
the supreme discipline of best film the
film's already mentioned not to compete
with marriage story Johto rabbit Little
Women parasite and Lamaze 66 the Academy
Awards this year will take place on
February 9th as usual in the famous
Dolby Theatre in Los Angeles the walking
dead world beyond is the second spin-off
of the main series and will be released
this year much about the content is not
yet known despite an already released
trainer all we know is that the story
takes place about ten years after the
zombie apocalypse and that the focus is
on a group of young people in order to
better classify the serious Scott M
Gimple one of the leading heads behind
The Walking Dead
now provide some information in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
according to Kimball the series will
stand on its own and the look
is the east coast of the USA moreover
the plot will be pretty much the same as
the current season of the main series so
it's no wonder that there are already
discussions about it possible crossover
behind the scenes but we can't assume
that this will happen directly in the
first season it should also be
remembered that the main focus is not
the crossover with the main series but
rather to show that the world of The
Walking Dead is simply more diverse and
bigger than we know it so far Kimbell
also gives a little hint about the
constellation of the teenagers namely
the group is supposed to leap they're
protected settlements in order to track
down the father of two members as well
as other things The Walking Dead world
beyond will be turn episodes at first
and will be released this spring on the
US channel AMC at the same time the
Sirius will be launched on Amazon Prime
similar to the first spin-off fear The
Walking Dead we can probably expect that
an exact release date will be announced
soon
[Music]